Il y a quelques années, je leur ai envoyé le mail suivant :
« Mes chers frères, j'espère que vous allez bien.
Je vous écris pour vous informer
que j'arrête mes études en ingénierie
pour poursuivre une carrière de musicien.
Je vous demande simplement de ne pas vous inquiéter pour moi. »
Mon premier frère m'a répondu.
Il m'encourageait mais restait réservé.
Il m'a souhaité bonne chance,
car j'allais en avoir besoin.
(Rires)
Mon deuxième frère était plus sceptique.
Il m'a intimé de ne pas le faire.
Ce serait la pire décision dans ma vie.
Je devais trouver une vraie carrière.
(Rires)
Mes autres frères étaient si enthousiastes au sujet de ma décision
qu'ils n'ont pas pris la peine de répondre.
(Rires)
Je sais que la circonspection de mes frères
vient de leurs soucis à mon sujet.
Ils s'inquiétaient.
Ils pensaient que ce ne serait pas évident de vivre en tant qu'artiste,
que le défi était important.
Devinez quoi ! Ils avaient raison.
C'est un réel défi d'être artiste à temps plein.
Tant de mes amis ont besoin d'un deuxième boulot,
un plan B pour payer les factures,
sauf que le plan B devient parfois leur plan A.
Il n'y a pas que mes amis dans cette situation.
Le bureau du recensement américain dit que 10% seulement des diplômés en art
travaillent vraiment en tant qu'artiste à temps plein.
Les autres 90% changent de carrière,
travaillent dans le marketing, la vente, l'éducation et d'autres disciplines.
Rien de neuf là-dedans.
On s'attend presque à ce qu'un artiste ait du mal à joindre les deux bouts.
Pourquoi pensons-nous ainsi ?
J'ai lu un article dans le Huffington Post
qui disait que l'Union européenne est devenue depuis quatre ans
le pourvoyeur financier artistique le plus important au monde.
L'Europe de la création met 2,4 milliards de dollars
à la disposition de 300 000 artistes.
Toutefois, le budget américain destiné au Fonds national pour les arts,
le plus grand mécène pour les arts aux États-Unis,
s'élève à à peine 146 millions de dollars.
Pour mettre ça en perspective,
le budget américain pour les fanfares militaires
est deux fois aussi important que celui du fonds national pour les arts.
Brendan McMahon, dans un article du Huffington Post,
affirme que si sur le budget de mille milliards de dollars
dédié aux dépenses militaires et de défense,
on allouait 0,05% à l'art,
on pourrait rémunérer 20 orchestres philharmoniques à temps plein
à raison de 20 millions de dollars chacun
et offrir à 80 000 artistes
un salaire annuel de 50 000 dollars chacun.
0,05% uniquement.
Imaginez ce qu'on pourrait faire avec 1% de ce budget.
Je sais que nous vivons dans une société capitaliste
où le profit est important.
Prenons donc l'angle financier.
L'industrie des arts américaine sans but lucratif
génère plus de 166 milliards de dollars en activité économique.
Elle emploie 5,7 millions de personnes
et paie 12,6 milliards de dollars
en impôts sur le revenu.
C'est juste l'angle financier.
Nous savons tous que l'art est davantage que sa valeur économique.
L'art apporte du sens à la vie.
C'est l'esprit de notre culture.
Il réunit les gens et soutient la créativité et la cohésion sociale.
Si l'art contribue tant à l'économie,
pourquoi investissons-nous si peu dans celui-ci et dans les artistes ?
Pourquoi plus de 80% de nos écoles aux États-Unis
subissent-elles des coupes budgétaires dans leur programme artistique ?
Quelle partie de la valeur des arts et des artistes
ne comprenons-nous pas ?
Je pense que le système est biaisé et très loin d'être juste.
J'ai décidé de contribuer à changer ça.
Je veux vivre dans une société
où les artistes ont plus de valeur,
reçoivent plus de soutien culturel et financier
pour se concentrer sur leur création,
au lieu d'être obligé d'être chauffeur pour Uber
ou de choisir un boulot d'employé qu'ils préféreraient ne pas avoir.
Il y a pourtant d'autres sources de revenu pour les artistes.
Il y a les fondations privées,
des bourses et des mécènes qui font des dons financiers.
Le problème est que la majorité des artistes ne sont pas au courant.
D'un côté, il y a les institutions et les gens avec l'argent.
De l'autre, les artistes qui cherchent des fonds.
Mais les artistes ne connaissent pas les gens avec l'argent.
Et les gens avec l'argent ne connaissent pas nécessairement
tous les artistes.
Pour cette raison, je suis heureux de partager avec vous « Grantpa »,
une plateforme en ligne qui utilise la technologie
pour connecter les artistes aux opportunités de financement
de manière simple, rapide et moins intimidante.
Grantpa est la première étape pour résoudre le problème existant
de l'inégalité des financements
mais nous devons travailler ensemble sur plusieurs fronts
pour ré-évaluer comment la société considère les artistes.
Pensons-nous que l'art est un luxe ou une nécessité ?
Comprenons-nous ce qu'il se passe dans le quotidien d'un artiste
ou croyons-nous toujours que les artistes, quelles que soient leurs difficultés,
sont toujours heureux parce qu'ils poursuivent leur passion ?
Dans quelques années, je me propose d'envoyer le mail suivant à mes frères :
« Mes chers frères, j'espère que vous allez bien.
Je vous écris pour vous informer que je vais super bien
comme les centaines de milliers d'artistes
qui sont mieux valorisés culturellement et financièrement
et obtiennent assez de financement pour se concentrer sur leur art
et créer encore plus.
Je vous remercie pour votre soutien.
Je n'aurais pas réussi sans vous. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)